Feast your eyes upon these light
transport simulation algorithms,
ray tracers if you will. These enable us
to simulate the path of millions of light
rays bouncing in a scene and create
absolutely beautiful photorealistic
images. Hmm…but there is a huge
problem. What is the problem?
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Now, look at the previous technique.
Here is the problem. Noise. My goodness,
so much noise, this would take quite
a bit of more time to get rid of,
and now have a look at the new technique.
These images are so much cleaner.
So, are they usable? Well, we have noise
filtering algorithms tailored for light transport
simulations. Are they any good? Well, let’s
have a look together. Let’s plug in the previous
technique into a noise filtering algorithm.
And the input has these walking light blobs,
so…are they gone now? Unfortunately not.
This is supposed to remove noise, not fix
these blobs. So let’s see what happens with the
new technique…and…oh my. I already see that we
have less noise, and after filtering…bingo!
Love it. Not perfect, but so much better.
So, let’s have a closer look at what just
happened. Here is a comparison with path
tracing. This is one of the first algorithms
you learn on your light transport class. It can
barely do anything on this notoriously difficult
scene. MMIS, this is marginal multiple importance
sampling, now this is so much better. However
with this, we also get lots of noise. This is
the ReSTIR technique that you just saw with the
blobs. This is from 2022 and gives us less noise,
that is good, however, look. The specular
highlights on the teapot are different,
they do not match the true simulation. It does
not give us the image we are looking for. And now,
look at the new technique, oh yes, less noise
and it is correct at the same time. This was a
particularly good case for the new technique,
but even on a selection of other scenes,
it performs really well. Better than its
predecessors. A solid step forward. Loving it!
And we are not done yet, not even close. I have a
bunch of incredible new papers on
ray tracing for you to marvel at!
When creating games and virtual worlds,
we often find ourselves having 3D geometry
that is not too detailed, but we would like to
make it look a bit more interesting. Slapping
a texture on it kinda works, but it is
still very flat and not very exciting.
Now we would like this geometry to stay
simple and quick to render, easy to store,
but at the same time, to appear to be a lot
more detailed. Look. So much better! This
technique is called displacement mapping
and it can make a really simple piece of
geometry come alive in your games and virtual
worlds. However, it is not new. Not new at all,
it goes back 30 years, possibly even longer.
So, what is interesting here in this new paper?
Well, two things.
One, hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars
because it can do all this up to 11 times
faster than previous techniques, now
is the point where I immediately think
that potentially by leaning more heavily on
memory, so maybe faster at the cost of using
more memory. However, I was very surprised to
find out that this was not only not the case,
but it also requires 3 times
less memory. That is incredible.
Two, it takes a possibly fractional level of
detail parameter. That is very cool. You see,
level of detail helps you save resources by
rendering a coarse version of a piece of geometry
and add details to it only as we get closer. This
is when we would see them, after all. However,
this often happens in steps, where you can often
see from detail level 0 to 1 or 1 to 2, this
object suddenly looks like this object. There is
a pop. However, look. With a fractional level of
detail parameter, we can make it pop a little less
and these transitions will look more continuous.
Note that other techniques can do this too, but
this is one more tool in our toolkit. So cool!
I also could not resist showing
you this real-time technique that
can simulate a bit of light transport, for
instance, it can do indirect illumination,
or color bleeding. This is the bleeding effect
of light as it bounces through multiple diffuse
surfaces and is a beautiful phenomenon in nature,
but unfortunately, less so in many virtual worlds,
because it is so slow and expensive to
compute. But not here. This technique
can pull off limited light transport but
in real time. And the implementation of
it is available on Shadertoy where you can try it
right now. And even look at the code or modify it.
And we are still not done yet. This new technique
can create this gorgeous material by shooting more
than 2 million rays at it per second, and it uses
less than 200 Megabytes of memory. That is almost
nothing for a geometry of this detail. This is a
SIGGRAPH ASIA-paper, which is perhaps the olympic
gold medal of computer graphics research,
written by a single author. Bravo Shinji!
And I would also like to show you this. These
gorgeous light transport simulations are done with
LuxCoreRender. This is a free, fully open source
renderer with many advanced algorithms. I used to
contribute to this project, wrote some code in it
and enjoyed every minute of it. It is an amazing
system still used by many-many people. And they
need your help. If you smart Fellow Scholars could
contribute, that would be absolutely amazing.
I have a link for you in the video description.
By the way, if you wish to learn how to understand
and write these amazing light simulation programs,
I have a completely free Master-level
course on it for you, where we build
up such a system from absolutely nothing. It is
completely free for all of you Fellow Scholars,
no strings attached. If you watch it, you
will see the world differently. Have fun!